donc je suis candidat sur la première
circonscription du tarn et garonne je
suis un élu de terrain je suis maire
d'une petite commune et vice président
de la communauté de l'agglomération
je suis très inquiet sur ce terrible et
vraiment ancré sur ce territoire et
c'est pour ça que je me présente pour
représenter évidemment toutes ces
tares et garonnais ont été délaissés
pendant cinq ans et qui risque d'être
délaissée 52 puis ensuite par rapport à
notre territoire les atouts sont
relativement importants nous avons la
ligne alger des vins qui se dessine avec
l'osr dans l'hôpital qui va être
construit avec un échangeur et
sincèrement ce territoire rural et 6
millions des urbains entre le lien comme
ça je vais en être un acteur
développement économique en occupant de
cette implication est à mon petit temps
de faire venir des entreprises par
exemple pourquoi je me présente avec sur
l'étiquette droite et nouveau centre et
bien parce que après de gaulle j'ai
suivi l'avènement de l'ensemble des
présidents de la vème république et que
pour notre france et pour mon territoire
pour ministres et je ne pouvais pas
faire autrement que de continuer dans
notre famille